just heat it up at 300 and leave it in
for 35 minutes thanks Karen it's my take
on Mexican lasagna great chef and I
can't imagine what you're going through
well it's like if Jeff got hit by a car
and died suddenly and violently like
that
well you get that dish back to me
whenever you can
welcome to friends have have looks like
we have so many people here today I'm
Beauty Jen helps us so we're can I give
you a hug no okay
I lost my fiance 8 weeks ago it's really
sudden she's Ted diet I got I've been
sleeping not it off okay I'm off all
night
feel free to call me we can sleep
together hurry did you get it him no
this man is probably in another one and
you're fine are you in bed
yeah what are you wearing a pair of
slippers yeah they are a weird person
they do this a lot just every time I see
a person sized dent in the front bumper
of a car but it must be hard to be alone
in that big house without Steve my guest
house is open be nice having you there
boys
this is Judy hey hey he thinks that the
bird is dead alert maybe it is him okay
it's weird being in there oh you don't
even know her she could be a crazy
person we're looking for Judy Hale why
are you looking for Judy let's just say
that wherever Judy goes chaos tends to
follow
[Music]
kind of game that you're playing there's
a lot of [ __ ] you don't know
brave doesn't merge its people I know
you you're good crazy enough
you invited a criminal into your home
she's the only person who's been here
for me that doesn't make me feel like I
am failing at everything I've got a
widow running around town like a white
wine magellanic
I miss you baby just wanted to say that
okay fine it's trying a thing [ __ ] you
too
[Music]
[Music]